sébastien huyghe bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors depuis
plusieurs jours des voix s'élèvent
notamment chez les policiers pour
dénoncer le laxisme de la justice
alors que le projet de loi pour la
confiance dans l'institution judiciaire
on disait elle doit être adaptée
aujourd'hui en première lecture à
l'assemblée nationale
pour le ministre de l'intérieur je vais
le site et le problème de la justice
c'est le manque de moyens dans la
justice
est-ce que vous rejoignez ses propos
est-ce qu'il est là le noeud du problème
c'est là c'est un des problèmes un des
problèmes de la police cité de la police
fait mais la justice aussi a besoin de
moyens supplémentaires
et puis surtout il a besoin d'être en
phase avec les aspirations des français
et les français ont souvent l'impression
que la justice est elle est laxiste face
à une société qui est de plus en plus
violentes et moi ce que je regrette dans
le projet de loi qui va être votée à
l'assemblée nationale même si on ne peut
pas nier voyez je suis dans l'opposition
mais je suis constructif même si on ne
peut pas nier un certain nombre
d'avancées
c'est qu'il ne va pas suffisamment loin
et nous les républicains nous étions
favorables à la mise en place à la au
retour des peines plancher qui
permettent de donner une indication
magistrats sur la volonté du peuple
français
qu'il y ait eu une retour de l'autorité
de l'époque de 2,2 de l'état et une plus
grande sévérité face à adé acte toujours
de plus en plus violents en tout cas
vous le soutenez ce projet de loi les
républicains vont voter en faveur de ce
projet de loi cet après midi écoutez
nous allons avoir
dans quelques dans quelques minutes
notre notre réunion de groupe où nous
nous déterminerons mais je pense que
quand un texte va dans le bon sens vaut
mieux voter même si on aurait souhaité
qu'il aille beaucoup plus loin le compte
n'y est absolument pas mais on voit
plutôt d'un oeil favorable et quelques
avancées qui existe dans son texte alors
un projet de loi composé d'une
quarantaine d'articles 1 parmi ces
articles
les deux mesures phare c'est
l'enregistrement sonore ou audiovisuelle
des audiences en vue de leur diffusion
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
mesure le problème c'est de savoir les
conditions dans lesquelles auront lieu
aura lieu cette cette diffusion
si ces enregistrements sont là pour le
jour comment il ya un procès
retentissant qui pose interrogations sur
la manière dont les choses se sont
passées tout cela peut être intéressant
aussi c'est pour faye tonné une histoire
et qu'elle soit diffusée à peu trop
rapidement là je m'élève contre eux
qu'on cette situation alors toujours à
propos des sanctions gérald darmanin
annoncé hier lors d'un déplacement à
marseille une amende de 135 euros pour
les squatteurs de halls d'immeuble
regarder les policiers auront la
possibilité de mettre une amende de 135
euros pour une personne qui occupe un
hall d'immeuble aujourd'hui il est très
difficile de constituer ce délit c'est
une pierre supplémentaire dans le jardin
des trafiquants alors une pierre
supplémentaire dans le jardin des
trafiquants c'est utile c'est suffisant
comme mesure selon vous écoutez le squat
de deux halls d'immeubles
avait été comment mis en place par
nicolas sarkozy il y a un peu plus de
dix ans maintenant
gérald darmanin
mais cette cette amende de 135 euros qui
correspond à la même amende si je puis
dire que le non port du masque et si je
ne m'abuse es6 es7 personnes qui
squattent les immeubles font du trafic
de drogue comme c'est souvent le cas
c'est peut-être une goutte d'eau dans
l'océan
et puis le problème c'est
l'applicabilité de cette mesure on
s'aperçoit que lorsque on fixe des
amendes de ce style elles sont rarement
appliquées
alors on fait quoi justement pour
supprimer ces dealers dans ces quartiers
sensibles pour supprimer ces
rassemblements selon vous pour moi on
est avec gérald darmanin mais comme avec
emmanuel macron toujours dans la
communication aujourd'hui on s'attaque
directement aux dealers s'est beaucoup
d'opérations de police qui font de la
communication je pense que le mal
il faut le prendre à la racine et c'est
plutôt s'attaquer pardon au trafic de
grande ampleur et et tarir la source
c'est-à-dire tarn et les trafics de
drogue et les arrivées de drogue massif
dans notre pays on vous casse gérald
darmanin et eric dupond-moretti montré
du doigt pointé du doigt en tout cas
leur action par la présidente de la
fondation des femmes à propos de cette
femme de 22 ans qui a été tuée par son
compagnon en moselle selon les premiers
éléments de l'enquète la victime avait
déjà déposé plainte pour menaces en
novembre dernier je vous propose
d'écouter la réaction de la présidente
de la fondation des femmes
anne-cécile mes frais gérald darmanin ne
se préoccupent pas de la cause numéro
une d'assassinât des femmes en france la
politique quand il s'agit du droit des
femmes c'est une question de vie ou de
mort pour les femmes
quand on a des politiques qui
s'investissent sur le sujet cela peut
fonctionner quand il se désinvestissent
et vont chasser les fumeurs de joints
plutôt que les tueurs de femmes
ça amène à cela vous rejoignez ses
propos de cécile mes frais je pense
qu'on n'en fait pas assez pour défendre
les femmes et on nous avons à déplorer
trop de décès sous les coups des
compagnons des maris ou des axes mari et
je pense que l'accent doit être mis dans
dans cette lutte
dans cette lutte pardon pour pour
défendre les femmes et notamment quand
il y à un signalement et bien ça ne doit
pas laisser ça ne doit pas rester lettre
morte
il doit y avoir une enquête et il doit
voir mise en sécurité de la personne qui
se sent menacée parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas la première fois qu'une femme
qui a déjà déposé plainte
meurt sous les coups de son compagnon ça
vient d'où finalement cette défaillance
je pense que tout ça doit remonter au
gouvernement et aux choix qui sont faits
par le par le gouvernement et donc par
le ministre de mettre l'accent sur sur
cette situation et de donner les
instructions pour que à chaque fois
qu'il y ait une plainte
un signalement une main courante eh bien
cela ne la laisse pas ne reste pas
lettre morte et qu'il y ait une action
derrière denquête et de protection alors
le secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes s'est exprimé sur la
question de l'immigration hier et il a
appelé à un renforcement de l'agencé
frontex est il appelé à ce que chaque
pays prenne leur part dans l'accueil
pour lui on doit avoir une politique
migratoire plus européenne
c'est le cas sur vous il a tout à fait
raison
dans ce cadre nous avons nécessité
d'avoir une politique migratoire qui
soit commune et que les institutions
européennes soient en capacité de faire
respecter les règles
d'immigration dans l'espace européen et
notamment de définir et de faire
respecter un certain nombre de critères
le droit d'asile aujourd'hui et détourné
un certain nombre de gens qui ne
relèvent pas du droit d'asile
s'introduisent sur l'espace européen et
le sentiment que ça donne à l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens c'est que l'union
européenne est complètement désarmée
pour faire face à ces vagues successives
et donc il doit y avoir une vraie
politique européenne commune avec une
agence frontex qui est les moyens
j'allais dire de nos ambitions communes
c'est à dire empêcher l'immigration
illégale alors en tout cas on pourra
circuler en tout cas à l'intérieur des
pays des 27 avec un pass sanitaire avec
le 1er juillet 2010 2 le 1er juillet
prochain pardon avec un vaccin ou avec
un test est ce que c'est une bonne
nouvelle pour vous alors une inquiétude
pour les libertés individuelles
moi je suis favorable aux opa sanitaire
je pense que la seule solution pour
lutter contre le virus et ne plus vivre
les confinements à répétition que nous
avons eue à vivre pendant cette grosse
année c'est des 18 derniers mois et bien
eux passent par la vaccination notamment
et donc il est indispensable qu'il y ait
un document qui permettent à ceux qui
sont vaccinées bien de se déplacer
normalement puisqu'ils ne sont plus ni
source de contamination ni elle ni à
risque et puis ceux qui ne veulent pas
se vacciner bien il est logique que il
ne puisse pas avoir accès aux eaux
comment la même manière de se déplacer
au sein de l'union que ceux qui ont fait
l'effort de celle de se faire vacciner
alors en revanche une condition un seul
les vaccins autorisés par l' agence
européenne du
médicaments seront reconnus regarder ce
que a précisé clément bonne
il n'est pas question qu'on arrive en
france avec un vaccin dont on n'est pas
sûr de la protection le vaccin dans ce
cas précis ne suffira pas qu'on vienne
de chine du chili ou de hongrie
parce que nous voulons être sûrs que les
gens qui viennent en france soit bien
protégée alors les vaccins chinois ou
les vaccins rue c'est bien ça ne marche
pas est ce que vous comprenez cette
condition et il ya le il est fait c'est
une logique
à partir du moment où on veut protéger
l'union européenne les ressortissants de
l'union européenne et bien doivent
s'appliquer sur le sol aurait p1 la
réglementation européenne et à partir du
moment où on a une agence du médicament
qui détermine quels sont les vaccins
dont l'efficacité est retenu et bien
pour ceux qui veulent venir sur notre
sol
ils doivent s'appliquer cette règle a
mené cette réglementation européenne et
donc moi je trouve tout à fait logique
que l'union européenne impose la
vaccination de vaccins qui sont
reconnues comme efficaces alors
sébastien huyghe on arrive au terme de
cette interview
néanmoins pour conclure un mot sur les
régionales vous avez tout juste trente
secondes compteur oblige la gauche unie
donc dans les hauts de france et le
garde des sceaux en campagne contre la
rassemblement national pensez vous que
sa présence puisse affaiblir votre
candidat xavier bertrand non pas du tout
on s'aperçoit que plus il ya deux
ministres d'emmanuel mâcon qui viennent
dans les hauts de france plus la liste
la république en marche baisse dans les
sondages donc c'est dommage qu'il manque
encore quelques ministres et puis là la
vraie question pour être très sérieux
c'est que une campagne ça se fait sur le
terrain et on peut se poser la question
de savoir si les ministres n'ont pas
autre chose à faire qui essayait de
dézinguer xavier bertrand qui fait très
peur à emmanuel macron pour la prochaine
élection présidentielle merci
beaucoup sébastien huyghe d'avoir
répondu à nos questions ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes député les républicains du
nord